welcome back
to the last section of a 20 special
relativity
so as we discussed the special
relativity itself
um also general relativity is a theory
which requires experimental evidence to
be confirmed
and there's plenty of experimental
evidence for general relativity we
talked about a few examples already but
let's go through this one by one also a
little bit within historic context
so one of the first
experimental pieces of evidence pointed
out by einstein was the
procession of mercury and also of other
planets
this was always
this
this this problem that the procession of
mercury deviates from newton's
prediction was well known and first
recognized already in 1859
and it turned out that attempts to
correct this are failed uh you can think
about maybe there's other objects in the
solar system which modify
the trajectory of mercury around the sun
but nothing really added up correctly
and then when einstein calculated the
effect of the possession he found that
it's in good agreement with the
observation
this was already very strong evidence
for general relativity effect
and then there is gravitational lensing
and here this was first measured by
dyson and 1919
of light passing the sun in a total
eclipse
their observation was in brazil but also
at the west coast of africa
this wasn't the first attempt to measure
this
it was an eclipse a total eclipse in
argentina in 1912 but unfortunately this
expedition didn't lead to a result
because it rained out
there was
it
eclipsed shortly after in 1914
but that happened during the second
world war and there's long stories and
and
accounts of how this
failed but basically one of the
expeditions
wanted to
travel to crimea
in in russia and because russia was in
war with germany um you know material
was confiscated and people were
imprisoned so this was cancelled if you
want due to the second the first world
war but then in 1919 this leads to the
observation this the data was not as
clear i think there was a little bit
more hopes than science in the
interpretation so there was
um
i was not a strong evident a strong
significance of the results but the
evidence nevertheless was there and as i
was explaining earlier that led to you
know the fame of the triumph of einstein
where really uh his fame resulted out of
the reporting of those events
there's more uh
experimental evidence live light travel
time but round or close to masses object
is modified
we talked about gravitational time
dilation which can be measured or has
been measured
um other tests of the equivalent
principle
but also the observation of
gravitational waves gravitational waves
where predicted by einstein by the
theory of general relativity and only
very recently we were able to observe
those
and then in addition there is plenty
cosmological tests which require a
precise understanding of general
relativity in order to get
to agreement between the observations
and
and the theoretical predictions
but let's talk about
let's talk about gravitational waves so
those were predicted as i was say was
saying but they're very very difficult
to measure
first indirect measurement
was performed by hulse and taylor
they were able to study a binary neutron
star system
and because
the orbital the orbits of those two
decayed
required loss of energy and that loss of
energy needs to happen somehow and
it was theorized or predicted by general
relativity that that loss of energy is
due to the fact that gravitational waves
are emitted and they received for their
findings in nobel prize in physics in
1993.
so how are
gravitational waves generated
you can ask you know i have a spinning
sphere like our sun would that generate
a gravitational
wave and the answer is no it's a
symmetrical situation there's no change
um
of the of the meta distribution and
therefore space-time is not modified
but if you have a sphere with a little
bump
that would create gravitational waves
if you have a mass which is moving by
maybe you know you know two passing
galaxies
that would not directly create
gravitational waves but if you have
those galaxies
rotating or through stars rotating or
neutron stars rotating or black holes
rotating around each other those
generate
gravitational waves and the closer the
objects the higher the masses of the
objects the stronger the gravitational
waves are
so how can you measure gravitational
waves
very similar to the michael snowley
experiment what you want to do
is measure
differences
in
arms of your of your
parameter
and you do this with very powerful
lasers and with very precise mirrors so
it's basically the very same uh
experiment as michael's molly just much
much bigger so we're talking about
multiple miles of arms and very powerful
lasers in order to conduct those
experiments
ligo which is one of those measurements
of those devices experiments measures
the change in the length of one arm
with a precision smaller than the
diameter of a proton
so that's just really it's mind-blowing
the level of precision the level of
understanding
needed in order to measure gravitational
waves but nevertheless
they succeeded
so here you see two experiments like was
actually two experiments two of those
devices
in the united states and there's
other experiments similar uh worldwide
now you see also highlighted here
carltec and mit
those are the leading
communities of the leading
universities in this endeavor
and then the first observation
of gravitational waves happened in
september 14th 2015
and this first observation was rather
spectacular because it was not just any
observation but it was
the observation of two collapsing black
holes so we have two black holes they
get close to each other then they circle
each other and
create a new heavier black hole so the
collisions are of those two black holes
this mass is around 30 times the mass of
the sun
it actually took place 1.3 billion years
ago so the gravitational wave was
traveling towards us for 1.3 billion
years
the energy
of about three times the mass of the sun
was emitted as gravitational waves in
fractions of seconds
so the huge amount of energy released in
form of gravitational waves
the collision happens with both black
holes moving with half the speed of
light so this is just a
catastrophic kind of event in our
universe
and
researchers or faculty at mit and
caltech received the nobel prize in
physics in 2017 for this discovery only
two years after the discovery actually
happened
and very deserved very deserved
let me close this lecture by just
reminding you of a quote of einstein
which i use in order to start this very
same lecture
um it is true
that we are living through some
difficult times
some turbulent times
but if you think about the bigger
picture where i think we're making a lot
of progress scientifically but also as
humanity
and i like this quote from albert
einstein a lot it is not the result of
scientific research that ennobles humans
and enriches their nature but it's a
struggle to understand by performing
created and creative and open-minded
intellectual work
i think if there's one thing i want you
to take away from this lecture it is
this i want you to be encouraged to be
creative to be open-minded to question
and to perform high-level intellectual
work
thank you
you